here with reaction Lieutenant Chris
Oliveira is with the Texas Department of
Public Safety let's take this as a
twofer first uh this lawsuit from the
Los Angeles City uh Council there have
been 435 to date illegals sent to Los
Angeles since June now 35
000 to democrat-led cities across the
country yet the city council says
they're overwhelmed they're gonna
they're gonna charge the governor what
do you say
well I'll be good morning so of course
another another you know nothing nothing
surprising about you know a sanctuary
City trying to file a lawsuit against
the state of Texas for actually
protecting our own State and doing
something about this actual border
crisis but the city council should
direct their complaints their
frustrations to the root cause of this
border crisis and that is the
administration they have created the
largest influx of illegal immigration in
our history and the fact that they have
not taken any immediate action to
prevent illegal border crossings between
the ports of Entry this is a result of
that that's why these Sanctuary cities
have resulted in a direct impact that's
why they have become a border states
because the fact that these illegal
immigrants they don't want to stay in
Texas they want to go to these Sanctuary
cities they declare themselves in the
sanctuary cities that's why that's why
you have to be careful what you ask for
because now these illegal immigrants are
going to be at their doorstep and to say
you know 400 illegal immigrants is going
to cause you know some type of you know
overwhelming of their system or their
City really is you know as a fraction of
what we deal with in Texas we deal with
close to 4 000 daily encounters a day
just in Texas alone these are legal
border crossing so that's nothing
compared to what we deal with and what
we've been dealing with for the past two
plus years so again they should direct
their complaints to the administration
who has completely caused this border
crisis and when you talk about that
Administration how about that statement
from the press secretary that no one's
done more in history it's sort of
reminiscent of Afghanistan and the
debacle there of saying what's the
greatest airlift in history uh they have
a way of spinning their abject and
intentional failures into somehow a
positive
you know Pete when I heard that I was
shocked to actually hear those type of
comments again you know from our own
government from our leadership saying
that they actually have done more for
the Border they have done more to slow
the flow well that that is a blatant lie
that's a slap in the face to the
American people to slap in the face to
First Responders that are on their front
lines every single day dealing with this
border crisis and also most importantly
those victims the families that have
lost some loved ones because of fentanyl
we know for a fact Pete that the numbers
have increased there's been a 30 percent
increase over the past two months 177
000 illegal border crossings for the
month of August alone those are illegal
border crosses between the ports of
Entry now you have armed gunmen that are
coming across our borders unimpeded
these are cartel operatives heavily you
know heavily armed wearing tactical gear
have they have armor piercing rounds
coming across our borders especially
having him you have an influx of human
smuggling uh unaccompanied each other
and Fentanyl is coming across our
borders to say that there's actual that
they've done more it's a complete it's a
lie if you really want to look who's
done more for border security it's what
we have done in the state of Texas When
government happened is done because of
operations OnStar and all the different
infrastructures he has put in place
because of that maybe they're talking
about doing more for the other side of
the Border no one's done more for the
other side of the Border uh than this
Administration Lieutenant Chris olivarez
thanks for what you do we appreciate you
appreciate it Pete thank you I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis